bill white keith hernandez tommy heard
john tudor all receiving their red
jackets in a big big crowd across the
street great speeches emotional and
wonderful to see them get their due so
here we go now the cardinals of 2021 and
bottom line they need to get a win
tonight and j hap could be the guy to do
it camel 0 for three last night drew a
walk
it's this hard to right field and that's
going to get down and get past newt barr
ben gimmel starts things off with an
extra base hit great way to start yoshi
suzuko pinch hit home run last night
yep gets the strikeout
so lead off double gamo left stranded
jay have to strike out as we move to the
home half of the first and tonight for
the pirates is going to be left-hander
dylan peters arenado last night struck
out three times
a little tapper
newman and that'll do it good work again
good breaking balls and a couple of
dandy change-ups stallings last night on
base a couple of times
and fights that off a base hit for
stallings
being recognized
shadow right
throw back and it's a double play if
newport drops this ball then he's going
to be out at second base anyway and so
why not just get back to the bag and
kind of force the issue that way but
there's the play clearly out nice play
by goldschmidt gregory polanco hitting
197. he had two sac flies last night
swing and a miss and a strikeout for
half number two tonight so the single
erased on a double play strikeout of
polanco
and new is coming up
there's tyler o'neil
that's up the middle and the cardinals
have their first base hit tonight off
the bat at tyler o'neill
when leading off and ending he's hitting
close to 3 30. and so he's a board for
yada yada molina molina is certainly a
double play candidate
strike three called molina can't
complain now there's a wild play
he wants
it he wants to but he knows large newt
part had three hits last night here's
the 2-1 and a swing of the liner caught
by hayes he left up and got that one
he put the rocket in his pocket
quick reaction soft hands newman's been
swinging a better bat got the slagging
percentage over 300 now pitch
swinging a deep drive to left o'neal
back to the warning track and gone home
run for kevin newman newman aligned
drive home run to left his fourth of the
year and the pirates lead it one to
nothing you can't uh rob that
you know again that's one way to make
sure they don't catch it hit it off the
ballpark and
even the foul ball the high fastball you
talked about the foul back uh he was
under it a bit i mean there's some
intention here's a one-two pitch and a
strikeout that's strikeout number three
d brian hayes grounded out to short
first time up the 2-2 pitch
swinging a mess
a couple of strikeouts
in the inning number four for hap but
you look up you got two outs in the
third ricky he's already had 53 pitches
there's tommy edmund with two outs and
nobody on three balls one strike on
tommy edmond
and he walked him 317 the average since
the break eight doubles five home runs
a lot of props for that
into rights oh it gets by
polanco couldn't come up with it
goalie to second tommy edmond scores and
we're tied at one right on the nose i
thought polanco was going to be able to
catch that that's the ball down middle
of the plate
there's the route by polanco and
looked like it went over his glove just
by a tan i think he thought he had it
measured up back to work tie game and
here is
yoshi tsutsugo who struck out on a 3-2
pitch his first time up against jhap and
now launches one to center field and
deep and so
hits another home run
yoshi
clears the deck
and it's two to one
we were talking in the
open about
what kind of a power hitter he was
before he came
over here to the states i mean it
it's there he's a great power hitter but
he just hasn't been able to show it once
he got over here been with a couple of
teams now will the timing be good for us
it's only been a few days but it's kind
of looking like that struck out back in
the second inning hapa struck out four
walked one
0-2 pitch
and a swing and a miss by polanco
strikeout number five o'neal molina newt
barr coming up and it's 2-1
you're doing them a disservice
there's a strikeout and perhaps that is
six tonight the 2-2 pitch
and he struck him out caught him looking
two more strikeouts in the inning he's
up to seven
tap is due up first when we come back
tapa has seven strikeouts tonight giving
up two solo home runs the one-two pitch
got him strikeout number eight
tyler o'neal base hit to center grounded
out sharply to third one for two 3-1
pitch
up the middle
tough to get him with his speed and he
is safe at first o'neill beats it out a
little hit and run here with yachty
there goes o'neal it's go time throw the
second and say
the 2-0 pitch
molina has tied the game up because
o'neill
racing to third
he'll score and we're tied to two
a pitch that jams him a bit
but he has the strength to get it over
the head of hayes into left field and no
chance now sosa one for two the one two
newport running base hit left center new
par off to the races he might switch it
to third being waved in
relay to the plate newport scores and
the cardinals laid it 3-2
an 80s rewind here the city
they're running and newport running with
that pitch he's already at second base
that's essentially a single to center a
long single
which is now a double because they throw
home a little shake of the head from
newman both times uh last year when he
came back from
undergone tommy john surgery the
previous year and newman battles
cabrera and a one out single so now
gamble
camel line drive base hit to right he
keeps it going and a little bobble
and heading to third base and he's there
a little uh gamble by newman on the
bobble by newt barr but he makes it and
gamel follows into second base brian
hayes good time to pick it up right here
and the other way in a base hit for
hayes
the gamble by newman will pay off in a
big way
as key brian hayes gets up off the deck
we're going to face tutsugo
and to left center field and that gets
down
yoshi suits sugo
into second base with another double and
this will score one but reynolds will be
thrown out at the plate tommy edmond
glide to center walked and scored
grounded out two short the 2-1 pitch
and a base hit for tommy edmond
the 01 pitch
out to left and a base hit the first two
have reached edmond stops at second
runners at first and second nobody out
one-two pitch
[Music]
it to left and it gets down camo could
not come up with it and the bases are
loaded
nobody out in the home half of the
seventh for st louis
the chance to do some damage here for
tyler o'neill the 2-0
o'neal with a high fly ball
in the left backing up gamma
one runner will tag that's tommy edmond
he'll score cuts the lead to 5-4 the
cardinals are one and 50 when trailing
after eight innings this year
o'neil pulls it
key brian hayes up with it
and the pirates will look for a sweep
here in st louis tomorrow
a fine play made by key brian hayes down
at third and the pirates hold on for a
game two win they've taken the first two
in this series